certainly the holidays can be hard on
individuals and families rocky spoke to
southwest medical the sponsors of this
next segment about ways to help with
depression at this time of year
dr orr welcome back
thank you for having me
you're just telling me that you know you
have a few kids at home it's time for
the holidays a really joyous time
but for a lot of adults this can be a
stressful time too right
absolutely you know while it can be a
very festive time of the year for many
it can also invite unwelcome guests to
your house including
stress and depression so it's no
surprise during the holiday we see an
increase
in depression with all the array of um
additional demands we have in our life
including shopping and cooking and
baking and cleaning and
entertaining family and friends uh all
that can increase the stress anxiety in
your life a triggered question
and one other thing i try to you know
remind people is this year we're having
a huge increase in uh
stress related to uh the ongoing
pandemic as well as economic stresses so
important to think about that
for sure and what are some of the signs
that we should look out for you know in
ourselves and in our loved ones yeah
that's a great question it's important
to recognize the most vital signs and
they would include
thoughts of helplessness and
hopelessness
irritability and stress
lack of interest normal activities
changes in your
sleeping insomnia is a common symptom
there's numerous other symptoms physical
findings such as dizziness and headaches
as well as lack of energy and fatigue
and difficulty with focusing and
concentrating so when should someone
seek help
that's a good question too if you feel
any of those signs or symptoms of
depressed mood you should seek help with
your primary care provider as soon as
possible
okay and dr orr when is when are the
signs considered an emergency
well they're considered an emergency if
you or someone you know may be of harms
themselves or have suicidal thoughts you
should call 9-1-1 immediately to seek
immediate care and attention if you know
someone's having a potential self-harm
it's important to stay with that
individual until they receive care so
call 9-1-1 while you're sitting and
waiting with them until they get care
preferably at a hospital emergency room
it's so important to pay attention to
yourself and your loved ones during this
time especially but if you're not at a
crisis level you know what are some of
the things that can reduce the stress or
reduce the depression
well one is knowing the holiday triggers
so we discussed some of those all the
stressors with extra demands
knowing what your limitations are not
overwhelming yourself you know getting
assistance from family and friends it's
okay to also acknowledge your feelings
quite often people recall the loss of a
loved one recently during the holiday
season so expressing those feelings
being realistic with what you can do and
knowing your limitations learn to say no
not to overextend yourself uh and know
your capabilities and of course do not
abandon your healthy habits and most
importantly reach out to your primary
care provider if you're having any of
these signs or symptoms of depression
for immediate attention and care
thank you southwest medical associates
for sponsoring that segment they have
locations across southern nevada if you
want more information you can call
702-877-5